[Music]
today on Battle Damage some people asked
us to do so we're gonna do it hi
we destroyed this printer now it's your
job to kill flies
it
as successful as secret tongue to it
[Music]
Jeff it's boring
let's smash a cat with it no buckle my
teeth today we're bringing you a special
console wars pay your chin back lift
your chin lift your chin with your chin
election today on battle to battle
tampon
I don't know I'm saying everyone's
favorite little action camera the GoPro
this is cool it's so good
you can request what we've battled test
next by leaving a battle tampon sorry
ready today on battle tent my head
[Music]
whoo man that was really embarrassing
help us feel better why don't you tell
us about a time you really screwed up
down there in the comments make sure and
check out all 12 episodes of season 1 if
you haven't already and we'll be back
next week with a brand new episode